a team of tugboats was put to work on a
stricken container ship today
but despite the considerable power of
their combined engines
the ever given didn't budge wedged
across the suez canal
the scale of the problem dwarfing the
machines that had been seen
as a solution it ran aground two days
ago but the company trying to free the
ship
warned it could remain here for weeks
creating a nightmare scenario for global
trade
the traffic jam it's created is already
more than 150 ships long
among their cargo oil gas and grains one
of the world's busiest shipping lanes at
a standstill
this is the maritime equivalent of a
blocked coronary artery
a hiccup like this sort of sets everyone
back
everyone was already scrambling to get
back to normal
and serve what has been quite strong
demand for
traded goods and yeah no one needs
another delay on on top of everything
else and it does underline
just how important and how finely
balanced
the whole system is the british
government said the incident could cause
delays for uk bound deliveries
while the japanese owner of the quarter
mile long ship apologized for the
disruption
it was supposedly caused by the vessel
being blown off course
by a sudden strong wind and a dust storm
but experts say
that's nothing new these vessels are
built for that and
these mussels are capable of handling
them so it's it
while it that could have been one of the
major factors that contributed for it it
also depends on the skill level of
the hung spent holes on the wheel even
at high tide the efforts to refloat the
ever given were futile
salvage experts and canal officials are
now considering removing containers to
make it easier to shift
but with up to twenty thousand on board
this is no quick fix
ifa bennett sky news